foreign
six
seven
eight
nine
ten
eleven
well
13.
15.
16 and 17.
Jacob as well
I'll move those minutes thank you very
much thank you all in favor please show
thank you
and he again
are abstentions
okay thank you
foreign
number three public contributions I
don't think we have any
number four Declarations of Interest
well ambushing all the score on that
point so if you have a need please
declare them when the item comes up
uh item five agreement uh agenda items
between part one and part two you've
only got any specific part two items on
the agenda but we may need to move in
departed items as we develop the agenda
item six to consider correspondence
brought forward by the uh direction of
the chair
um
no true
[Music]
weapon seven to answer questions
submitted under procedural rule A9
as you can see the question submitted by
councilman Haynes uh announcer has been
circulated
Pastor James
it's a supplementary
um
yeah I just wanted to ask where the
record will be the head to a very long
compliance with the lectures they needed
to produce I have been
[Music]
um
my understanding that the the records
will show those who haven't or turned
possibly turned up and haven't provided
but I think the guidance and the details
are still being gone through so I
believe so Council means information
I'm not sure whether it doesn't work in
constantly that's absolutely really
changes
okay I took eight petitions a
non-received
I want to move on on to item nine the
local plan review Pages 18 to 262.
I'm sure you've all read them
uh Helen Smith Barney manager is going
to present a report
thank you
you've got five minutes
yeah I used to like whatever it is
good evening members
um I'm not not going through all 200
Pages you'll be glad to hear okay and
I'll set out in your gender for this
evening the purpose of this particular
report is to resolve the appropriate way
forward with the update to the local
plan
and by way of some background and
context the the north Devon and forage
local plan which covers a period from
2011 through 2031 was adopted by North
Devon and Parish District Council in
October 2018
um in response to a range of local and
wider influences and configurations a
decision was taken by both councils in
late 2020 to to work together to
comprehensive review and update
This was um developed under the banner
of the people in place project which I'm
I'm sure you've all been familiar with
um and the the project was based on a
schedule of Works which was agreed by
the The Joint planning policy Committee
in January of 2022.
in response to a changing local and
National context
um in July 2022 officers were tasked
with re-examining
um whether to live in a comprehensive
update to the local plan and Remains the
most appropriate course of action and
this was
recognition of external matters such as
the challenging
um local government environment
government Finance position and
forthcoming National planning reforms
and all the normal selection on the
performance of the plan at that time
with the adopted plan
over the last few months
um officers have been involved in extent
in the extent today program and work
um to inform the appropriate way forward
this has included a detailed technical
assessment of the current government
closure plan and the appendices to your
agenda for include the toolkit review
Parts one and two which is an extensive
analysis of the local plan and how it's
performing and it's also been further
extensive engagement with members with
you as members through a series of
workshops to to get your feedback on how
the local plan is working for you and
the communities that you represent we
also joining with North General Council
secured external support from the
planning advisory service so they have
provided input and a critical brand
service along the way which has been has
been really beneficial
and as you all know the joint planning
policy committee has delegated
responsibility from this from this
Council for all matters relating to the
preparation of the development plan
other than formal adoption of course
um however the decision to carry out the
comprehensive review back in late 2020
and predates that the joint planning
policy committee being established and
therefore I just it was a decision by
school council at that time
therefore this this matter as to the
Future direction that the review should
take is is brought back before
university school council today
um a comparable report will be
considered by North Devon councils for
Council on the 22nd of February so
they're replicating this
um
a very detailed and comprehensive report
was considered by The Joint planning
policy Committee of the founding on a
Friday and that's the extensive report
that's appended to your agenda this
evening and I'm not proposing to go
through that and so the delegated
committee have already done that and
discussed it on a Friday afternoon and a
series of options were presented to the
Joint planning policy Committee in five
auction
um and an on balance recommendation was
made in that report to move toward a
partial review subject to a number of
caveats which will set out and the that
recommendation was accepted by joint
planning policy committee
um with Apes members waiting for two
against and the full recommendation was
published on Friday afternoon so
hopefully you will have all seen that
um
so today the recommendation is whether
it's for full Council to consider that
recommendation and resolve a way forward
with the local plan and chair I
understand that the lead is Keen to come
in first as a member of jppc
James thank you chair
um
a natural way to start
um I think we deal with this award in
part one repeatedly said well is that
the report that came out Friday
afternoon was not presented to us at the
jppc meeting in the morning and whilst
it does show things that we could look
at what we've looked at since there is
no clear guide to what actually will be
included in the partial review and uh
which ones because there's quite a few
of things that is in the policy you
cannot do under a partial review so what
we don't want to do is end up doing a
lot of work and then finding out that
what we've done doesn't qualify as a
partial review it has to be a full
review now in this spring and I lose the
term spring Loosely we are told there
will be as part of the level it up
document there will be more additional
planning guidance and in the Autumn we
are expecting the environmental bill
which will give more clarity about
biodiversity and stuff so my
recommendation is slightly different to
what's here and that is we do not look
at doing a full review at the moment
we continue on the principle that we're
looking at part uh partial review but we
go back to the JPC in the next meeting
and say what are the members actually
looking for within that review and look
at that which ones they're looking at
can be done within a partial review so
that we actually Target where we're
going but no because at the moment all
we've got is a general policy that we
will look at some of them and I know I'm
fairly passionate about the um the Royal
uh strategy but that cannot be looked at
as a partial review so if we roll things
forward we can start looking at a full
review in November and then we will have
a new up-to-date policy
um within 30 months of when we started
in November so at the moment I'm
recommended we don't do a full review at
the moment we ask the jppc committee to
come back with exactly what they're
looking at in a partial review
um what has been what members won and
also what can actually be done within
that partial review at the moment it's a
little bit of how long it's a piece of
string so I would ask that we deferred
the decision to get an answer back from
the jppc and then we bring it to the um
full Council early in April with some
proposal of where we're actually going
that is my recommendation thank you Chad
thank you that happened
questions you know sorry it's
contributing thank you because
in principle I I concur with that could
ask the planning manager is that
feasible
yeah so the the full recommendation
doesn't include physical was published
on on Friday afternoon
um at part c
um a need for the scope of the updates
established the appropriate development
plan vehicle for its delivery be
established and a revised local
development scheme be presented to a
future meeting of the jp16 now one of
the members
um
it might have to hang battery over the
the JPC PPC did ask what what the agenda
would be for that next meeting in March
and that's of course to be agreed with
the chair and vice chair however it was
expressed anything by myself that the
scope of a partial review has to be
agreed as a priority so that will be
looked at subject to the chair and vice
program at that next meeting so I would
say it is it is feasible that there will
be more information after that meeting
as to what that's going that would be
okay chair thank you for that are you
suggesting therefore that we as full
Council retain that decision or at the
moment in the report that decision is
actually delegated to the jpbc I said I
think leader you're suggesting that
actually
it comes back to full council with the
topics to be reviewed and that requires
our sign-off is do have I got it right
the policy that we pursue has to be
agreed by full Council right the jppc
can make recommendations of what that
should be and if you go back originally
we said we wanted a full review we are
actually at the moment still in that
position that we are looking for a full
review it's not practical given the time
scale 12 months ago it might have been
given where we are now
um it's not practical but also
some of that we feel that we shouldn't
be going into a partial review when
we're not sure what we would we're
reviewing and also whether that fits
within the criteria and and as it says
in the report we need to scope where
we're going and then therefore the jpcc
should make a recommendation that comes
to our next full Council and and I I
suspect it will be that we we do do some
focusing but we need to know what we're
focusing on and we don't want to be
wasting time on something that we're no
told we can't I should also make clear
this doesn't affect the five year land
Supply that work is going on and
hopefully that we may be looking at
about the end of March Maybe
okay thank you thanks
thank you Mr chairman as Vice chair of
the gpcc it's currently chaired by North
Devon Norwich takes over next year
uh so I can second the councilor James's
proposal
the facts are whether we liked it or not
the preparation of a local plan is a
very long involved and expensive
business
with the consultations that have to be
made of all sorts of contractors and
goodness knows what then to the public
then public inquiries
we've got to get it right
and the trouble is we could get it what
we think is nearly right and the
government changes
so just at the moment it would be
foolish to plow on
and catch an objective proposals where
we work along quietly get things in
order ready
it must be the right way to do it
and in any event this Council can't make
a lot of decisions In fairness is an
election in May and the new Council May
hello have different ideas
thank you Mr don't leave the agenda oh
he cancels the James's current answer
thank you chair yeah
in any event we're gonna have to um a
full review of our local brand starting
in the October or November we have to
have a we'll have to start the process
of reviewing the local plan then anyway
and I would like to see officers at
tortoise or over in North Devon doing an
awful lot of work
that really it could feed into that
review
but without knowing exactly what things
we should they're supposed to be
reviewing I can't really see the point
of doing very much at all until we've
got to do a full review
I mean the government now we're talking
about scrapping The Five-Year housing
land Society in the next I don't know a
couple of months or whenever there's
lots of things as was mentioned that's
coming through that Helen has mentioned
the government is changing so much
almost monthly on planning so I don't
like our offices to get bogged down with
a lot of review work
some of it might be useful when we do it
at all uh new draft new plan start that
but I wouldn't actually is doing a lot
of just talking and coming up with
maybe changed this a bit without
I've been putting a lot of work into it
until we start the full review of the
local plan in the Autumn okay
yes I'd agree with our leader that you
know this is the way to approach it but
could I ask just one thing when I looked
at the
um the supplement
um a form
um this apparently we're going to
recommend it's going to be recommended
full Council policy Provisions which no
longer conform to the majority views of
the councils can I ask what the
mechanism will be if we're actually
doing that
thank you councilor Christie so the
wording Within part A actually comes
from in part the guidance we receive
from the planning advisory service that
that sort of a terminology that they use
and a sub points one to four sets out
sort of
potential components of a partial review
um
we've already done some member workshops
which which have helped to inform
the recommendation that was before jppc
on Friday I think where that's coming
from is
you know are our members have been with
with the plan and the policies are there
Elements which on balance members would
like to see change but then obviously
the important following question is
um Can those aspirations be achieved
through a partial review or not and I
think that's where councilor James is
coming from if I understood him
correctly
um or if there are elements that can be
addressed through a partial review then
you know they would fall within that but
that could be certain
elements that no longer conform to the
majority of these
members of the councils which can only
be dealt with through a comprehensive
review and there is an extensive
appendix to the jppc report which goes
through all of the issues that were
raised by members of the workshops and
then whether they can progress through a
passion review so that gives an initial
scope of what could be achieved
here can we just come back on that
vehicle the workshops were very informal
and a lot of councils weren't there
um and what I was trying to ask is what
is the mechanism for this Council
actually deciding what those policies
will be and whether we want them changed
is there a committee going to be set up
or a working group or what well we have
the joint planning policy committee who
delegation Authority has given but the
majority of local plan matters their
words through whether it's a partial or
a comprehensive review be fair the
member engagement and workshops to
establish that scope and then officers
would consider those those points and
the extent to which they can be dealt
with their partial with you or a
comprehensive review or indeed whether
in some cases there are matters that
that can't be addressed through the
local plan and could be addressed
through other means so there's lots of
different options there but I would see
any whether it's a partial or a
comprehensive review they're being
by the program of member engagement
Kevin can I just say although the JPC
so you're in issuing it now
um has the authority to take decision
now
it still comes back to full councils for
gratifications
right so that essentially is our
trigger on them if anything flies up
but you've got all the knowledge on your
work
so can I just come back chair right I
think when when we when we establish
what the jppc are looking at and what we
can actually make a difference to I
think we do need to feed back to members
but I'm not into this we know we're not
telling I'm not into that at all I think
we need to find some way we haven't got
a lot of time because you know we've got
to get on with this when
we might have been able to do it
differently but we are we are where we
are so I think obviously can sort of
through the jppc find out what we can do
look from the map the workshops some of
the things that are plugged up and I
know you know we talk about in KPCC when
turbines tourism
biodiversity
law strategy those are the things that
keep coming up and I know they're very
general terms
um but I think once we know which ones
we can look at and what we're looking at
I think we need to feed back to all
members because you know we pay we want
feedback you know I can assure you I go
out of somebody else for you making
these decisions
um and also that when it comes to full
Council we have to feel that it's our
our input and um I know Peter said not
uh comes to Christie so comes to
Christie that um there was a we had a 9
turnout from towage on the workshops
over the two nines um let's just say our
partners struggle to make 50 so we have
been fully committed to this and I just
want us to feel that when we do it it's
ours or be it it's ours in Partnership
okay thank you chair
okay we've got another full discussion
it's been proposed by
Professor Holmes yes I just look I've
got every sympathy with accounts that
James is supposed to
um uneasy about you know the time it's
going to take you to do all this we've
already had a long delay because such a
source of the source problems with this
local fan review
um councilor Christie said we've had
workshops and it's highlighted the sort
of issues which people are concerned
with Cancers are concerned with that he
comes I had the opportunity to go to
those workshops and there's some clear
discussion points that should come out
of those workshops
um I'm a bit concerned that if we vote
to
um sort of find out what the scoping is
and then contact to this Council that's
going to delay things
for us we should put our sort of faith
in the joint committee to follow the
recommendations or the issues that came
out of those workshops really want to
get on with it
okay well no one else wishes to speak
it's been proposed by coach of James
seconded by councilor thanks
all in favor of supporting that
resolution be sure
okay
those against
and abstentions
foreign
thank you Helen
item 10 on the agenda shared Prosperity
final submission and I believe Chris
Fuller is going to give you the
presentation thank you Chris
yeah
over here
okay so um I was asked to come back and
give an update on progress with shared
Prosperity fund uh it was submitted back
in July uh 2020 I think the day after 11
minutes so it's a bit of an interesting
uh for a long time
um as a reminder to members this was a
fund that was announced in the webinar
white paper and Professor the last to
submit a three-year investment plan with
a shared Prosperity plan being billed at
the time as being the replacement for
European funds that the family coming
into the district
foreign
[Music]
um
it's important to know at this point
that soon after perchbear Prosperity
fund we would then uh get informed about
the rural Prosperity bonus which was the
funds that came down from Deborah
um but uh moved back in October
um that was
built at the time by death River there's
a fund that was supposed to support
delivery of the sharing Prosperity plans
just to make it nice and confusing for
everyone
um therefore have still not informed
anyone about the outcomes of that one so
that was the balance that was looking to
support uh the capital works on the
Torrington Market Hall uh to support
Victoria Park and benefits and where we
had the proposed leader-style Grant
scheme to support uh rural opportunities
across storage with the kind of
designated part to sport Leisure and
culture
um hopefully we'll hear on that one any
day next
as a reminder and we did have that
million pounds over the three years
um with a small amount in for this year
that was supposed to be mainly around uh
preparing some of the elements for
delivery in 23 through to 25
um thinking particular as a business
sport program that was approved for
North Devon plus to be running
and the final year about 24 is over at
night is where a lot of the main
European funding will drop away style
impacts our organizations such as supply
of Health interventions and big
organizations like pet dog who delivered
and
business supports and employability
students using that European funding
that we um
so again just a reminder that we were
expected to go through kind of a process
and we gave them with multiple
stakeholders and as part of that and
each district had to have an external
steering organization
assigned so that was the northern Devon
Futures board
and Steve and perhapsody as well we then
had inputs from the regional Action
Group looking at uh kind of innovation
and skills as well as kind of feelings
and various different organization uh
other elements of terrorist District
councils to make sure that we can
support uh wider delivery Traders
um where kind of the span is in the
investment plan but in 2022
um to 2023 I've said
we are the announcement came three
months after the expected which puts
slight pressure on that one but the the
feedback that's been given by debug is
that
um that funding can still be carried on
and the payments would only continue for
23 and 24 as long as they have a clear
plan for delivery and how that can be
enacted when the funding was initially
announced uh it was announced that we'll
get the funding for 23 24 when to spend
between 22 23 has been delivered which
kind of filled with every local
Authority would Panic instead of playing
Justice that uh I just couldn't believe
in those three months that would be
challenged and back then that's now been
ironed out I'm sure there'll be some
paperwork that comes with it but I was
always
so to give kind of members a quick walk
through
um the
range of topics um
the first two years
um
one main thread around communities in
place and one mainstream programs and
business support So within kind of um
the the best way that the communities
are based that entails things like
[Music]
support the town centers cost of living
sport of design outcrime correct can I
just interrupt in a second because just
pause for a second well that's a
question you get to the chair what's in
front of us so we can put the monitor up
we can't quite read it so yeah I can
blame it's struggling to see over it
sure
not that simple
thank you
for a minute
um
so this is where uh We've managed to
work with a number of other teams across
the tourism Council of offices to make
sure that for example opportunities can
be sought to uh and
uh for example help for Estates and the
community liaison teams with CCTV in
great Clarington and bitterfield
and we had hoped to support anytime team
looking at uh support the retrofit
um activities web often part of the or
uptake is about simply making people
aware that the funding is available and
building the trust uh on that and so
kind of the more Outreach uh marketing
that can be done that's targeted on that
really does help boost those numbers I
think that's why it's quite pleasing
that we're now able to work through one
little Devon with primary care networks
who are actually then able to go out
specifically to those people in most
need where that funding really will have
the most impact a small amount of money
will hopefully go I don't know when we
make an impact on that one
um in terms of the top point there
taking over a big new maps have been
uh long vacant my words difficult to
actually find who despite the fact that
their units have been awakened for a
long period of time are willing to
actually move it forward even when we're
offering them um Capital planning to get
that unit back into the market
so it's a real insight into the fact
that there's some good landlords and
someone that we really do need
to shake up attention with neatness and
so that's that's why
[Music]
where the ambition has always been to
make sure that this funding can really
start creating change rather than just
small simple ways
and then the support for the business
interventions
again when things start to come through
um in terms of town center kind of
interaction Town Center members was
around the desire to really see that
vibrancy and vitality and activity
building football and it's the first
time about seeing support given out
through our funding experiment by this
to actually over and explore markets and
start attracting uh Market providers to
be doing more in the area it's actually
been quite exciting to see coming
through
[Music]
um
it's also being connected up to the work
that we're doing through the economy
Innovation skills
um Action Group which is also has direct
moments to be working out before
looking at where the difference uh
business funding roots are so not just
sort of added grants but also the
expected is clear Maritime and
Innovation sort of uh growth in the area
making sure that things like
um
the engine investment and the private
investment routes are in the routing
towards-based businesses and that's
where we're punishment that uh part of
the southwestern that actually started
and mental scoping piece on this that
we've able to kind of amplify and make
sure that rather than having a
generalist look across the region can
have quite a direct focus on the
opportunity in Torres and North Devon
which is quite exciting to get voted
and again better support for the
biosphere and then
that are finally
[Music]
and making sure that we're providing
that business support that was approved
by members for you know what that we
must so the next two years making sure
that that underpinning support is there
for businesses
um
[Music]
the business supports landscape is
uncertain at the moment but it's a lot
of government funding streams
disappearing so that it's actually going
to provide that underpinning guarantee
that there will be actually supports
available business over the next two
years
thank you
[Music]
just nature
okay thank you sure any questions
for your foundations commercialization
measures made
Gary Wilson this is a commercial
opportunity where where companies would
be attracted to
um bio to offsets in
in areas of land and why do they leave
Singapore Finance
so this is a program of activities that
the council voted to support previously
um and where the movement biosphere
um have been making uh investigations
and building some really fascinating
Partnerships so
um is around how you can use with uh
please don't ask me for too much detail
on this one because I'll start
scratching my own head uh so the concept
of natural councilor elements so where
we've previously been seeing as kind of
because you're rule because everything's
green and beautiful and therefore
uninvestable that actually by protecting
that
um sort of green natural beauty through
those Maybe
directing offsetting payments for
example but actually into genuine
projects working with Farmers across the
region to make sure that actually that
investment isn't just doing what some
offsetting projects done you buy a field
and just leave it to rack and ruin
but actually making sure that there is a
strong
regulated and supported pipeline of
funding between community in a managed
way to help agricultural projects across
the region at a time when we know that
this farmers are really facing a
challenge so if we can invest and make
sure that actually Northern Devon is
seen at the Forefront of that which we
are currently being seen as that
platform it just strengthens the chance
that we'll have that stronger level
investment information
um
hope you understood that kind of names
okay thank you that's just been open but
thank you
so moving on to item 11 the Strategic
asset plan major
270-336 and Sean Connie is going to
present the report
thank you chair
so it gives me great pleasure
to present to you the long-awaited and
much needed uh strategic asset plan for
the federal district
uh the document in front of you uh is
set into three sections that's a
management policy strategy and an action
plan
the policy identifies the high level
objectives and priorities for our asset
management and use
it gives some context looking at the key
issues of the district and what we need
to be trying to do and also it sets out
some organizational context around what
our other strategies we've got going on
and how this our assets can fit into the
user their use can be fitted into those
it's so eight override principles which
determine our approach to real estate
which is really good and helps us Define
what we should be doing the strategy uh
sets out an overview of our asset
portfolio it looks at the governance
arrangements and decision making that
we've got within the council and also it
considers the risk of using our assets
in different ways and the asset
management plan is much more granular
document that comes down to things on a
more asset right asset basis project by
project basis
so I really don't have too much more to
say uh chair other than uh this is a
really important document across it's
been identified as a a risk Beginning by
auditing governance and our Auditors
have picked it up
um it's been what we haven't had one in
2017 and if we're going to be efficient
uh in the use of our assets for the
greatest benefit for our communities I
would like to recommend it's adopting
back
a habit checking questions
Professor Haynes yeah
thank you Chad um
yeah I'm thinking about you put it down
to 25 226 so reducing the list of
possible porridge assets which could
possibly dispose of
um using this rather a long time ahead
is it really that complicated and
exercise to draw that such of this
and secondly other thing is will we be
receiving some sort of reports on those
candidates amongst our properties for
cargo remission reductions obviously
something which you might consider very
important
uh yeah so so uh in answer him's
question yes it is quite a complex piece
of work we have a huge portfolio of
assets and to go through the asset by
asset basis and and put them through the
framework is a is a large piece of work
uh what we don't want to do is open
promise and under deliver so that's a
reasonable time frame that we put on
that
um and obviously we can do it faster we
will in terms of uh carbon efficiency
we've obviously got a joint climate
change officer working through
um uh producing studies and reports and
we can look at uh documents uh sorry uh
look at assets on an individual basis in
the internet doesn't mean we sort of
have a standstill until we have a ground
plan and if opportunities are presented
um we can take those in the interim so I
don't think there's a big Hiatus period
until we've got a master plan in place
[Music]
thank you
yeah I'm pretty sure thank you
that's awesome
thank you chair I think this is an
excellent man
um it is actually for the first time
since I've been part of Torres laid out
a very clear picture of our assets with
a clear plan and I think
um what Sean has explained to us it's a
timely
adoption how we're going to deliver this
because sometimes we have
um strategies and no delivery plans but
this has actually come together as a
single document and I really think it's
excellent
just to prove I've read it all sure we
appear to have got a property in Bristol
of page 290
um we have a
property at oh Jurassic
but if you can have a look at it and I
don't know if we've got an interest in
Bristol thanks Joe yes
uh it's a legacy of our um when we had
cancer houses and had a housing stock
and uh to be honest we don't know the
detail and something we're going to have
to consider quite closely because it's
something we might want to understand us
whether we still want to have a property
in Britain all right that is plenty of
view that we've got an Investment
Portfolio in uh
far away land thank you
sorry there wasn't there isn't in that
concern as well that I was asked to
point out by Chancellor Jones uh there's
a section that Leicester our assets and
it mentions Clifton Heights and it's
caused some concern locally that it says
football pitch football club and
Facilities uh it should just read
football pitch because we don't own the
football club and the facilities that if
it's the
um uh The Pavilion building it actually
belongs to the whole city takeouts so we
can get that amended
okay was there no other
questions it's been proposed by cancer
Hackett sorry yeah two at the back
cancer called honey thank you oh
yeah
okay so that can come later that there's
still some work to do in the final
section where we need to look in more
detail of each of the uh individual
assets that we've got the play areas are
listed in the um play strategy document
don't forget and that was taken into
account in the formulation of this
document
you want to come back yeah well it says
it's got the investment just repeat it
and the recreational so I'd recommend
that that was added from the bottom and
play area
so I don't see why we can't have a fair
area site listing recreational Sean yeah
members won that we can get that okay
okay
[Music]
thank you chair uh chair under the
investment Holdings he being important I
know Bernie Hill and Windmill Lane
I'd like to make counselors aware
of the parking situation in our small
towns and villages
if you would sell it decide to sell
those and I know you haven't or develop
them you wouldn't ignore them absolutely
stoned down and I will be starting a
campaign shortly to make the people
aware of the danger to their communities
and the same applies to Corrington
I'm a very trying to have this parking
around a wonderful view which is where a
million pounds of a resale Market
but it is we can't make it aware they
have to be made representation because
uh it's very very important and the
business communities of Northern and
China thank you
thank you okay offering no further
questions it's been proposed by
councilor Hackett seconded by Coast
arranged that we
accept the report as outlined
all in favor please show
yeah
[Music]
and again representing or abstentions
okay moving over to item 12 Brunswick
land release fund Pages three three
seven three four two
um
um so I I won't go over the long history
of uh the Brunswick wolf development
because we've uh we've done that one a
few times uh but you will recall that uh
your offices big application for 797
000 pounds was successful and given land
release fund funding to help the
development viability of the project to
expedite its delivery
um previously we hadn't truly understood
the conditionality around that Grant and
we became aware that uh it wasn't uh the
conditionality didn't go away at a point
of release which has now been triggered
but on the development of the 53rd units
so that's where the risk of claw back to
the council uh diminishes completely
um we've brought a couple of previous
reports that explained that and we were
asked to go back and bottom this out and
this is where we've got to in this
report
um within the report uh I've added some
comments in from Reddit who owned the
site or the developer uh they've talked
about how they uh have established the
deal set it up and had structured
finance and they talked about their
views on some of the risk management
propositions for the papers can we've
investigated any number of different
options around charges around Covenant
um the site contracts all sorts of
different things and uh we've got to the
view really that there is no way of
completely de-risking this grant
um it was it was applied for to uh to
expedite the delivery as I said before
and if members want to do that they will
have to do that entering into the into
it with the knowledge that there is an
element of risk associated with this uh
the conclusions uh basically summarize
the situation for you and and go through
what just said and then the
recommendations are in front of you as
seen you can accept the principle of the
subordinate charge to make the grant
Awards red Earth that he will work
uh the sum of 797 000 pounds would need
to be added to our Capital program and
this option provides a limited risk
management but would facilitate some
enabling works and development the risk
still exists until the 53rd units
developed as I've mentioned and I think
it's on a diminishing basis to every
unit would mean lesser paid back if the
the an alternative use of the Cycles
agreed uh B is make the grunt Awards to
Red Earth for the key wall without the
subordinate charge
or any other form of Rich mitigation so
the sum of 797 000 pounds would need to
be added to the capital program again
and this option provides no risk
management a grant pullback in the event
of delivery of non-housing on the sorry
non-housing delivery on the site but it
would facilitate the development
obviously or you do have the option uh
to not to make a grant Awards to redo so
it's over to you members to decide
whether you wish to make the grant
Awards with any traditionality without
conditionality or not thank you
councilor again
thank you chair
um I'll try and bring some order to that
could I asked first of all that we go
into part two and then we can have a pop
program discussion about the finances
and then make a great Foundation we come
back into part one with the
recommendations where we're going with
them
thank you okay it's been proposed
seconded that we go into part two to
discuss this all in favor please show
again
under the abstentions
okay that's clearly carried so are we
our futures
foreign
Community
right so
we're now back back on YouTube again so
we need to be very clear as to exactly
what the recommendation is
go for the three-letter Renditions we
come up with earlier
so can I just have concrete codification
and to keep inside please
sure I I believe the recommendations are
um that the council
would have initially prefer the primary
charge for release of the 797
000 if the developers not happy or
content with that then the option from
the council is on a risk-based uh
risk-based basis uh we would offer 400
000 pounds on completion of the key or
Works to the required standard that
would form a
um a subordinate charge and the second
four hundred thousand would be released
on substantive development of the
housing site and site of a development
contract
if the developer's not happy with either
of those options uh then we would
withdraw any offer funding and we
discuss with d-lag whether that could be
reallocated or we just gets clawed by
the government Department I think
those are yeah
recorded vote please
okay
vote
[Music]
that's clearly solid okay
so we're all clear what the
recommendation is
uh according to James you're proposing
that and a second in podcasting YouTube
was it
was so
sure of hands all in support
um
recommendations of what's your name
did you have a second for that
would appear or not so it's going to be
that's not an option
um so it's been proposed it's been
seconded Sandra can you do them all
please
councilor bright against
LeBron
councilor bushby or Spencer Christie
against
councilor Clark oh
that's the Cotter pumpkin
or
thanks to craigie Legends cancel the
dart or
cancel the governor or councilor Hackett
or counselor Haynes
Council of Hawkins against
councilor hippo for counselor Hicks
against
the Hobson for counselor Hurley or
cancer inch or
counselor James or counselor Langford
against councilor laws or pencil leather
or that's a lot for Chancellor mcgoth or
councilor McKenzie against councilor
Manley or Pennsylvania Newton well
thanks for the Pennington against
cancel the wood house
chair that's 19 for the motion and 11
against
the time
item 13 is the pay polish requirements
the local news on that Pages
334348. as you can see there's a nice
activist on the top table now
2011 requires English and Welsh local
authorities to produce a statutory paid
policy statement each Financial year
so the principle is to increase
accountability transparency and fairness
and reflecting of local pay
policy applies to those officers whose
terms and conditions reflect those
determined by The Joint negotiating
committee for chief officers so at
Torres District Council those for
offices are chief executive head of
communities in place head of legal and
governance and the finance manager
the pay for these officers respect as
part of the management restructure in
2020 with external advice from Southwest
councils
the Hudson report in 2011 on Fair pay in
the public sector determined the most
appropriate metric for calculating pay
dispersion is multiple of Chief
Executives median earnings should this
be greater than 10 this will be reported
by the leaders of full Council for
cooperation the current pay multiple is
5.6
so it's a requirement to publish the
agreed Pace payment on the council's
website and this needs to be approved by
full Council by the 31st of March each
year
so James yes thank you so
it's the same the same references as
last year it's just the bombs gone up
because obviously all the every staff
members had
1925 so the bomb figures have all gone
up but the other figures have gone up
but the different entry is the same
I'm quite happy with it I propose that
so it is I don't think we do challenge
now Okay so we've been proposed seconded
by
that's the clock all in favor please
show
okay
[Music]
any against
any abstentions
[Laughter]
thank you
item 14. notice his emotion there
oh no question yes really is
notices of motion uh as you know I did
speak to you during the week about the
notification that character London put
forward and wasn't accepted
uh for whatever reason I don't know but
I recall that when we went through the
Constitution
I was very adamant and notice emotion or
sacrosanct remember to think each and
every one of us have a right to put
forward a momentous emotion
and although it says in the Constitution
cancel
um the notice motion must be about
matters uh for which the council has
responsibility or or which affect the
district and that's a capital phrase or
effective District because
anything basically it means
and please let us not slide back the bad
old days in the 80s
when the administration then were very
dictatorial
and I recall pulling forward a notice
the motion to do with bullying where I
remember uh Council councilor tried to
intimidate a bully and when we're stun
off and put more in a notification
against that
clarify the position of the councilors
and staff
respond forward I just accepted what
went forward but they refused to debate
it
and I refused to sit down
and lo and behold the police were
outside and they came from an exported
me out
you know that was 1989 the real Tory
administration number
yeah
it is an important point is that it is
at all that every member has here and no
officer or even a chair although you
have that discretion it's true up to a
point
it's almost emotions should be accepted
rubbish what's the problem
thank you I just say it I believe
foreign
if you want to put another symbol open
then please do but I would just check
with the chief exactly somebody the
wording is okay and then that way we got
something that we can vote on and not
sit here discussing whether it's correct
or incorrect okay
nice emotions but I would just suggest
that we get it right and Cheryl's been
told that that consequences
no you can't make any stipulation like
that at all if you're such a dimwit that
you put forward a real rubbish notice of
motion which isn't totally you know
illegible and we did have a chair of
this Council who is virtually illiterate
yeah yeah we did because
that that that's for the counselors all
right if it's that bad
don't send it end up you know and if
it's beyond that hurdle then don't vote
for it you know that this is democracy
and health sakes the my parting shot
when I was taken out by the police was
remember Mussolini started with councils
thank you president I think virtually
everyone would agree what you've what
you've said and understanding no I I do
president but I I was going to say what
basically what comes with Jameson you
know there are some little emotions that
and individual countries may wish before
so I all were really asking is that if
you're unsure of that the term of
knowledge is wording or whatever it is
you know whether it falls but then again
authorities and cancer please take
advice that's all you can still put the
motion forward but just get a bit of a
bit of Officer support a bit of
influence
the leader of the council he said that
he would have supported the legislation
at the next meeting
thank you
I always know you in the morning can I
just remind counselors that I did get
through the full Council that notice the
motion are actually restricted to less
than 200 words
okay that draws us to the end of the
meeting counselors thank you very much
for your patience anything